you know what causes anxiety
Woori stress a sense of chaos
disorganization a sense of being out of
control you can't control enough of the
variables in your life everything is
controlling you that is stressful when
everything is chaotic and disorganized
and out of control and just barking
loudly at you that chaos is called
stress it always induces stress and
always induces anxiety it always causes
that and so in any area of our life that
we want to lower our stress increase our
peace we have to create order out of
chaos I can remember something as simple
as when I was a little redneck kid we're
running in and out of the house and you
know running the fan in the door letting
all the air conditioning out in the
middle of summer it's hotter than blazes
and kids are running in screaming out
little boys running in screaming all the
neighbors me everybody else my sister
running around screaming everybody
screaming was chaos and I remember my
mother she was pretty patient for a long
time but eventually she would say that's
it I've had it
the worm has turned we didn't even know
what that meant except that the beatings
were getting ready to begin so it turns
out the worm has turned to Shakespeare
who knew mom knew Shakespeare but um and
right after that the chaos she would
exalt exert her will over the chaotic
mess and bring order to it and that was
that you were going to straighten up and
fly right you ever heard your mama say
something like that you gotta straighten
up and fly right or go get out of here
go play in the traffic something like
that right we're gonna get this house
cleaned we're gonna get some order to
this chaos and then our stress level
comes down so that makes sense if you've
got a chaotic mess and things and
there's no
order to it and I'm not a complete
organizational freak I'm a little bit
OCD more than a little bit probably but
I get tremendous peace from things being
in order and I have to exert my will to
think you know things don't naturally
move from chaos to order that's a that's
an act of force you have to force that
to happen how do you get order in your
money first step is getting a budget
telling your money what to do instead of
wondering where it went it's flying off
everywhere you got no idea where it went
all the money comes in all the money
goes out just the heart has worked
another month on another month older I
feel like a rat in a wheel there's no
sense of traction there's no sense that
we can't even get the bills paid we got
too much month left at the end of the
money and you have to exert your will
over that chaos and make it get in
control you have to create change an
order out of the chaos and order out of
chaos is not a natural function it's a
function that is an act of your will
your emotions your spirit your intellect
you have to force order to come from
chaos it does not naturally come from
chaos order is not a natural state chaos
is a natural state and so you have to
force order in your life when you do in
the area of money that's called people
say things like I was empowered yes you
were empowered you took power over the
mess and you said that's it the worm has
turned you people are going to
straighten up and fly right and you're
talking to your Benjamins right Benjamin
Franklin you're gonna straight up here
and fly right you're gonna do what I
tell you to do I work too hard for you
and you're not gonna just leave and I
don't know where you went and that's you
talking to your money you have to impose
your will and cause order to come out of
chaos and it's not a natural state this
is why most people do not win with money
why most people work their whole lives
and in many
make really decent money and have
absolutely nothing to show for it
because they took the path of least
resistance and chaos rule their life
they always had anxiety and worry and
stress around the subject of money
instead of going that's it the worm has
turned I've had it I'm sick and tired of
being sick and tired you uncle Benjamin
Franklin's you hundred-dollar bills are
gonna line up and fly right you're gonna
straighten up and fly right and you're
gonna get on the budgeting well I've got
everybody's got an excuse for budgeting
you know I've heard them all you know
what they're a bunch of bull I don't
hear your distinct excuses you're livin
and you're not winning so you have to
try something different try it my way
for 90 days if I'm wrong you can go back
to your way right doesn't cost you
anything get on a budget you can get on
a budget on a yellow pad get out right
at the top of the page what'd you make
this month and then spend those dollars
right down the page so much on food so
much on lights and water so much on the
house so much going into savings so much
going on my dad and give every one of
those dollars an assignment on a yellow
pad if you want you can put it into a
little spreadsheet on Excel if you
wanted to you want do it real simple
jump on the every dollar budget app it's
free takes about 10 minutes to get your
every dollar budget app going and so
there's just no excuse for this and
what's weird is that we human beings
we're a little bit psycho all of us we
would rather sit in the middle of stress
and chaos then get up off of our
assumptions and go change our life by
doing a budget you can argue with me
about our little budget is a good idea
and there you sit stressed out broke in
your poop and you know the only thing
you're sure of is it's warm and smells
good and smells bad it's yours get up
out of it and go change some stuff now
it's not going to change until you
change it the Democrats aren't going to
change it the Republicans aren't going
to change it
the lefties aren't going to change it
the righties aren't gonna change it no
one is coming the Calvary is not coming
you are the answer you are the special
sauce you will cause order to come out
of chaos and until you do you're gonna
have stress and you're gonna have
inefficient use of the money and you're
gonna feel like you work so hard and
can't figure out why you get to no
traction you have to have a plan and
winning is an intentional act no one
accidentally wins when the Super Bowl is
over Sunday they will not interview one
of the players on the field they will
not walk out there and say so what
happened he'll go I don't know I just
got off the bus and he just had no it's
that winning is an intentional act
he didn't accidentally end up there
didn't accidentally end up in the top
one half of one percent of athletes in
the world playing a game that hinges on
nanoseconds he didn't accidentally end
up on that field he didn't accidentally
end up in that level of physical
condition he didn't accidentally become
the best in the world winning is an
intentional act and the same is true
with something as simple as making your
freakin paycheck behave no more excuses
every dollar is free you got a yellow
pad in your in their drawer right there
pull it out most of you got Excel built
into your stinking computer there's no
excuse
jump on there get the every dollar
upload it takes 10 minutes we're the
best in the world it's showing you how
to do this I'm gonna make it as easy as
I can but making order out of chaos is
never an easy task but it's always worth
it
taking your marriage relationship which
is falling apart and bringing order to
it by imposing your will on the
situation changing the way you treat
each other so that your marriage
prospers and survives is an intentional
act causing your kids to behave is an
intentional act that some of you need to
engage in making your money behave
is an intentional act you're bringing
order out of chaos check this every
dollar stuff out folks it absolutely
works if you don't use our stuff I don't
care use a yellow pad but today's your
day the worm has turned